how's it going everybody it's Warren
it's an awesome day today because we
have some leaked set photos from the set
of Matt Reeves is the Batman this is our
first look at anything from the Batman
giving us our first look at what to
expect from the movie and luckily for us
with these set photos we see Robert
Pattinson as Bruce Wayne and we even see
Colin Farrell as penguin if you're new
to my channel be sure to subscribe I'll
be covering the Batman extensively I'm
also giving away next box 1 or a ps4 all
you have to do to enter is subscribe
when notifications turn on like the
video and leave a comment below so as I
mentioned these leaked photos are from
the set of the Batman in London and what
we see in these photos is that the
Gotham police is there Gotham Water and
Power is there and two gotham new
stations are there as well
and although the actual contact stuff
what is going on is unknown it seems
like they're holding a press conference
but what this does tell us is the period
in time that the Batman is going to take
place we have the Gotham police driving
old crown of Victorians and as we can
see on the side of the new station van
they are advertising HD broadcasts no
new station has advertised HD broadcast
in over 10 years pretty much every
single news station has HD now so that
combined with the old crown Victorians
that the Gotham police is using that
means that the Batman is most likely
going to take place in the early to
mid-2000s and this makes sense because
it's going to be somewhat of an origin
story for Robert Pattinson as the Batman
is going to take place in the early
years of Batman's crime-fighting career
and we actually see Robert Pattinson as
Bruce Wayne on a motorcycle on the set
of the Batman he appears riding up on
the bike with his helmet on and then we
see him take it off if this is in fact a
press conference it seems like he was
wondering what it was about which makes
sense because if it would involve a
crime he would want to know what it is
it said that the Batman is going to show
signs of the Batman in his early years
as an investigator so we're going to see
him actually try and solve cases and
figure out who people are not just bash
people's faces in which of course we'll
see as well so this is our first look at
Robert Pattinson as Bruce Wayne
unfortunately he's not in his Batman
costume but with these leaked set photos
coming out it's only a matter of time
it's also believed that this character
in this photo right here is Colin
Farrell as
and actually as I was recording this
Matt Reeves tweeted confirming that this
is in fact Colin Farrell as penguin and
he probably confirmed this because of
the leaked photos as you can see here it
is clearly Colin Farrell in this photo
and as you can see he has an umbrella in
his hand as well which is classic
penguin so this is our first look at
penguin as well in the Batman and to
wrap it all up with these set photos
there's actually a easter egg in these
photos one of the news vans on the side
says Gotham Action News 4 and Gotham
Action News was also the midday news
program in 1989's Batman directed by Tim
Burton so expect this movie to be filled
with tiny little Easter eggs like that
as well so these are our first leaked
photos of Matt Reeves as the Batman our
first look at Robert Pattinson as Bruce
Wayne in our first look at Colin Farrell
as penguin most of the cast has already
been established and it's fantastic so
far so let me know how excited you are
for Matt Reeves is the Batman and leave
your comments below about our first look
at Robert Pattinson as Bruce Wayne in
our first look as Colin Farrell as
penguin don't forget to like the video
and subscribe when notifications turned
on to stay up to date on everything
relating to the Batman and of course
Marvel news and so you can enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or ps4 don't forget to follow me on
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof